hi everyone and welcome to the first
hope of pi data yerevan as robert said
um armand
and i'll be speaking about data
standardization the what the why and the
how
so let's get
started okay
so um
let's look at what's on the menu for
today
um
so first we will talk about the context
of the problem so data standardization
is pretty vague and it could mean a lot
of things for a lot of different
contexts so
at first we will nail down the
a problem context in which we're talking
about data standardization then we will
talk about what what is data
standardization itself and why should we
standardize the data and most
importantly how to do it
okay
well the context
a lot of businesses especially the ones
that
were created during the tech boom of
2000s and 2010s
the
approach there was to rush to solve
short-term customer problems as fast as
you can as good as you can
and
in the
process the businesses didn't prioritize
right data collection and ended up
having insufficient data to innovate
further
so what what should we do then
um
yeah so let's probably define like what
it is insufficient data
consider an e-commerce website
uh where data comes in it's a
marketplace where there are buyers and
there are sellers and the data comes in
from a lot of different users a lot of
different sources and as you could
imagine like the same product could
be named in a lot of different ways for
example like there's a website that
sells home appliances and there's a
fridge and there's a refrigerator which
both mean the same thing but they are
written differently they're spelled
differently and if you'd like to
calculate the distance between them
using like naive string distance
algorithms like levenshtein distance you
wouldn't have much luck because these
two are very far apart from each other
in terms of the symbols
in terms of the characters
and so there's no good way for us to
understand that fridge and refrigerator
actually mean the same thing and if it's
just the marketplace and you just upload
your items to sell
you won't be able to scale a lot and
we'll see why and how to deal with this
problem the solution is to standardize
the data
so what is data standardization uh this
definition i've come up with it feel
free to comment if you think this is
incomplete but data standardization for
me at least is the process of cleaning
and storing data in a way that would be
consistent across all data sources so
wherever the data comes in from
it should be consistent and should have
consistent representation
everywhere
okay let's take a look at this example
here to the right in the screenshot you
will see the fourth most visited website
and the largest online marketplace in
armenia and this screenshot is actually
the search result of the search query of
iphone
and
you can see that when we're looking for
an iphone we get a lot of irrelevant
stuff as well like there is an iphone
charging brick there's an iphone screen
and there's also whatever that apple
iphone icloud
is supposed to be
uh yeah and now i'm looking for an
iphone and i'm presented with this um
like irrelevant uh
items to me
and it's for me as a user it is hard to
find and filter what i'm looking for so
if i'm looking for an iphone i have to
scroll through hundreds of pages to
actually get
some quality results for me to be able
to compare so there's no ranking to the
search here because
the website itself doesn't know
what is an iphone and what isn't an
iphone what is it just an accessory so
there's no ranking and of course to me
as a user i'd like to understand if i'm
buying something maybe i want to know
the price range or who are the sellers
where they're located and again i can't
do that because the products are
scattered across hundreds of pages and
to me it would be a very hard exercise
to go through every single one of those
pages document everything maybe drop it
in an excel sheet for me then to be able
to compare
um
yeah and if you think this example of an
iphone is bad just take a look at this
one so this is for the car parts and
this is the search result for a term
bumper guard but in armenian we call it
zashitnik which is
yeah of course a russian word but all
the armenian car part names are in
russian so yeah and you may see that
when we're looking for a bomber guard in
this website we find um a lot of weird
things like
car trunk nickel which is definitely not
the bumper guard and when we are asked
the question why do we see this when we
search for a bumper guard we notice that
a lot of like this seller has actually
put a lot of keywords
that
um are irrelevant to this part that
they're selling but these are just
different car parts so they do this to
bump up their items in the search so
they're trying to hack the system and
actually get better listings so
to get better customers and this is an
example of how this poor user experience
can lead to people doing this kind of
hacks and of course as a data collector
it spoils the data because to the car
trunk nickel there is attached like a
lot of this different irrelevant
data
so
um if at some point we'd like to
standardize this data
there is two ways to do it so let's say
the business solved the short term
customer problem and now they're they've
hit the plateau and now they can't scale
what should they do uh of course they
could change the
software in a way that wouldn't allow
this um craziness to happen that
wouldn't allow people to put everything
and anything that they want and that is
the forward-looking type of
standardization where they introduce
some taxonomy to their software to their
website
uh whatnot so here we can see that um
this website that i just showed examples
from actually at some point tried to
make this so there's taxonomy so for
example for an iphone there is just a
make condition color all these
attributes that they've added so that
it'll be easier for users to browse
but then let's say you're at a point
where you are putting these changes in
your software
but
what to do with the data that you
already have because during throughout
the years you have accumulated a lot of
data
and you need to somehow use it or wait a
couple of years until this new changes
bringing new clean data so that you will
be able to deliver features but in that
case the market is not just going to sit
there and wait your competitors are
going to beat you so you need to do this
backwards uh data standardization
to the help of data science and machine
learning and
okay
so i think by now just from the
definition of the problem you
already probably have some sense of why
we should standardize the data so any
ideas
anyone
filters
yes filters is one of them
ux
yes yes
exactly and yeah
so all of those uh like in some shape or
form are introduced in this pyramid of
standardization as i'd like to call it
so this pyramid in concept is similar to
uh maslow's pyramid like the basic human
needs so at the bottom
part at the bottom layer you have the
most fundamental uh things and then
everyone that builds on top of that has
to rely on the previous layers so what
is the very first layer of
standardization it's the ability to be
able to match things match items and
in this example i'm talking about an
e-commerce website but this could be
scaled to any number of systems where
the data comes in from different sources
so let's say in the e-commerce case what
is
the ability to match
it is
uh if we have in our database like two
different items like an iphone 13 pro
120 gig and apple iphone 13 pro 128gb
those two are actually the same thing
and again through the help of naive
algorithms we can't understand that
these two are the same but if we use
some if we are able to match these two
together it will unlock a lot of new
things that we could do
and the next next thing is removing
duplicates
so
um let's say we can already match and
when we search for something we don't
have to scroll through a lot of pages to
get what we're looking for but instead
if we're looking for an iphone somewhere
we will see just a single listing of an
iphone and then every offer listed under
that so for me as a user it'll be really
easy if i'm browsing for an iphone i'll
just click on one thing and i'll see all
the offers i'll be able to compare
everything everything the information
about the sellers the prices the reviews
and then it'll be easy for me to make a
decision and buy or not to buy
okay
so let's say we've removed duplicates
what's next um it's it gives us the
ability to analyze so uh and
this analysis could come from different
standpoints like as a seller it'll be
interesting for me if i'm putting out a
listing it'll be interesting for me to
see like what is the average price what
is the minimum price what is the maximum
price for something for an item that i'm
selling and again currently the customer
experience is not very well
because we'll have to manually scroll
through everything to find what the
price range to find what we're looking
for
and
of course there's also another analytics
role which is like the software creators
themselves they'd also like to know like
what what items are being sold through
my website so that the website will be
more
tailor-made for those kind of products
and maybe put more emphasis on that and
again without matching and without
removing duplicates we can do this
analytics piece
what's next is
as suggested the ability to build models
that would predict or recommend
something
so for example if i'm a user who's
looking to buy an iphone there's a
really high chance that i'm also looking
for an iphone
screen guard and you know case and maybe
in other apple accessories so
it is also important to understand what
item you're selling so that you will be
able to provide
contextually correct recommendations and
also make predictions about what's
what's going to be built next
and finally as you've seen in the
screenshot
a couple slides back there was no
personalization to search so whenever a
search is a search query is submitted it
just shows everyone the same thing and
in 2022 it is just not acceptable
because everyone has their own interests
and has a very small attention span so
they have to get personalized content to
be
to be interested to use that
service that website that software more
okay
yes now
from this pyramid we can see that if we
solve the matching problem which is
probably the hardest one out of all of
these we will be able to solve
everything else so let's concentrate on
matching itself
what is a matching again in the context
of
e-commerce websites the e-commerce
websites have products that they're
selling and what is a product it is
basically a combination of three things
in general
a name
an image
and a price
so
theoretically if we were able to match
all three of these components
to one to another
then for different products we will be
able to understand if two items are
similar or different
and uh the main topic of this uh i will
of this talk will be i will more
concentrate on the name matching piece
and then also provide some resources at
the end of how can the image matching
and price matching be done
well name matching let's formally define
the problem that we're trying to solve
is given a pair of product names output
if they represent the same item or not
okay so why is this such a big challenge
why can't we easily do it by string
comparisons we've already
discussed uh some difficulties but here
are um like formal challenges that we
will face in that process
first is different naming conventions as
said like there are multiple ways to
name the same thing so for example like
here 128 gig and 120 gb are the same
thing and like there is a keyword apple
in the right example and not it doesn't
exist in the left example
and that is like the brand
brand name they are omitting brand names
and also another thing another challenge
is that there could be synonyms that are
used for example unused versus brand new
which mean the same thing but again if
they mean something in within a context
and they
without a context we just can't
understand if these two are the same or
not
another challenge is the challenge of
vague titles so
some sellers just list the products as
like generic iphone 13 with no
specifications
and if we're comparing it to a very
specified product uh
we will not be able to match again
because we don't know if the
you know the specifications match to
this vague one
um also when i was uh preparing these
slides and i searched for iphones to get
the screenshot for that slide
um
i got a lot of weird priced
iphones like you know 100 200 which is
ridiculously low for iphones and it
turned out that those items those
iphones were fake and they were listed
under
under just regular iphones so there was
no way
there was nowhere that it is indicated
that it is a fake product
and of course the challenge is that
if you haven't invested in proper data
collection you probably don't have label
data enough label data to be able to
build models
okay
what to do then so then in order to do
any type of machine learning on this
data at hand uh we will need this to do
this five steps to generate the data set
that we will build models on
so the first step is tokenization
which is given a product name try to
understand what are the tokens and we
will see that this is not a trivial
problem because just splitting stuff by
space is not going to cut it within the
context of this problem
and yeah okay let's say we've tokenized
the data then we will need to understand
what each of the tokens are so we will
need a round of named entity recognition
to understand what each part of the name
means
after that we will need to identify for
each named entities they're appropriate
synonyms and antonyms which i'll
describe and bring
bring examples of
and after that
to
fit it into a model we will need
positive examples and negative examples
so items that are similar to each other
labeled as such and items that are
different from each other and labeled as
such if we have enough of those we can
build a model and
get our
standardization results
so let's see again this
talk is like heavy with iphone examples
i apologize for that but yes so this is
a product can someone help me tokenize
this name
yes
and
let's let's tokenize the rest as well
it's apple iphone 7
[Music]
yes but that that is the naive approach
which could be weird because like for
example the keyword sierra here doesn't
really mean anything in the context of
iphones because it always appears as
sierra blue so the sierra itself is not
a token in itself and like this 13 pro
max also is like one entity so we
shouldn't treat it as three different
tokens because then if we do named
entity recognition we will have to flag
all of these items separately and that's
just not good and also in the future if
we will try to learn some embeddings for
this it will not be
appropriate as well because
it's better to learn one embedding for
the color than like two different
embeddings and then do something
so yes
this is the tokenization that i've come
up with it could be argued that the 13
pro max should also be separated but
just for the sake of this example let's
keep it this way
and yes to be able to do this
tokenization we can use techniques such
as pointwise mutual information to
understand if these two tokens should
appear together and if they appear
together treat it as a single token
instead of two different tokens
yes once we do that then we are ready
for named entity recognition
now there are um
different approaches to this and at the
end there are some papers linked on how
you could do this i won't dive too deep
into it i'll just say that we can
um especially for phone related stuff if
the data set is primarily for phones
there are a lot of data sets on the
internet where each where there is
basically a dictionary of brands
dictionary of products dictionary of
model storage colors everything so the
very simple way would be to just
download those dictionaries and try to
apply it to your data set just brute
force apply it to see if anything like
matches 100
most of the times it will be enough to
have at least some
small starting data set for you to be
able to train this custom named entity
recognition models
okay
once we have this we need to identify
synonyms and by synonyms here i mean
that if within a name we exchange one
thing with the other the product itself
won't change so calling something uh 120
gb versus 128 gig is it's basically the
same thing just with different name
conventions
we can also think about if we're talking
about shoes for example or anything that
requires physical sizes you know the us
measures in inches and feet and in
europe it's in centimeters and meters so
yeah those things are all could also be
converted and matched together
and also like for the color as well like
sierra blue is sometimes is just
referred to the blue iphone so those two
are again synonyms in the context of
this data set
and yeah and the antonyms are the
opposite of synonyms
um which is um if we change that part
the product itself will change
so
if uh instead of apple we put samsung
then it's just different brands and it's
not the same product if instead of
iphone we put you know galaxy s22 ultra
it will be different product so yeah
basically antonyms if we are able to
identify them which again we could do
through the help of um
the
basic parsing of
dictionaries that could be found
available on the internet
okay once we understand these we need to
put it all together so um the first step
here would be to search your data set
for possible token matches so you have a
list of hundreds thousands millions of
items you just
try to compare or want everything to
each other to understand uh if there are
any possible token matches so if like
apple matches an apple if a samsung
matches to a samsung and if enough
things match
um
and there will be at least some level of
matches like no data is
entirely dirty there is at least some
level of cleanness in the data
so once you find it you need to collect
all the matching pairs and form positive
pairs like that
and
for negative pairs it's a bit easier so
if we sample two random elements from
the data set
and they don't have any token matches
which there would be a very high chance
of because
the probability of two things being the
same item it would be very low in
generic data sets like this yeah
that's how we can generate the negative
pairs
and for the edge cases like the products
that are uh spelled differently but are
actually the same thing or vice versa
they are the same thing but they are not
the same thing but the names are very
close for example iphone versus an
iphone case
what we can do is we can swap out tokens
with their antonyms to generate negative
pairs so for example if
we have you know an apple iphone
something we will swap it out to the
samsung iphone something and
we'll get negative pairs and we can do
the same with synonyms to generate
positive pairs and this will help the
model to
see the examples where only one keyword
makes all the difference
in this matching exercise
yeah and once we put everything together
we will end up with a data set like this
which will be enough at least to start
building some
models to see if we can
um
you know
do this matching and standardization
so the first step to building the model
would be generating name embeddings
and these embeddings
in a lot of blog posts and papers people
claim that for some um for some data
sets uh basic like birth embeddings or
you know gpd3 based embeddings work well
well it depends on how common your data
set is i for iphones i'm sure it'll work
because iphones appear a lot in
the data sets on which those big models
are trained
but if you are dealing with a very niche
you know specific data set it will be
hard to
get um accurate and good embeddings from
um
you know those big models so i would
suggest just building your own name
embeddings you're starting simple like
board to back or glove embedding should
be enough to start the modeling exercise
also some people just train their
embeddings through their
they put the embedding layers part of
the network that they're gonna build so
that is also an option and it depends on
the
data set and also it's more of like the
phase where you need trial and error to
understand what works well for you
okay and now for the model itself um
basically mostly what you will see in
the literature is for this kind of
examples like to understand if two texts
are similar or different
um it's
always almost always use this siamese
architecture
and within this branch networks
you will see either convolutional layers
or
recurrent
recurrent layers like lstms
and another um
example of a network that works well in
these
in this context is concatenating two
embeddings before supplying it to the
model so instead of putting it like
input one input to separately like it's
presented here
one could concatenate the embeddings
before fitting it into a model and
sometimes in my experience at least it
works a bit better
than
than the siamese networks
okay and hopefully after this you will
get high enough accuracy so that you can
proceed with the other components so
what's next let's say you have the model
you as
we talked about earlier you will need to
have another model to compare images
so
again there there are a lot of papers
that um
are telling about how you can do that
the architecture is similar so again
siamese networks are used to understand
the difference or similarity between two
pictures
and
then we need to do price similarity
which could
seem like it's a trivial problem because
price is the easiest to compare because
it's a numerical feature and you can
simply just subtract one from another to
see how close or far apart they are
but again it is very hard from the
context to understand like for an iphone
is hundred dollar price variance is it
is it accurate is it not if are they the
same or not
and uh for that what we could do is when
constructing the initial data set we um
hopefully we have at least some
accurate and clean matches and
through the help of that matches we can
form like clusters for product prices
and then whenever a new price comes in
that we would want to compare to that
product price we could treat it as
outlier detection problem and use it and
solve it through hypothesis testing like
the hypothesis would be that
the
the new price is an outlier and we will
try to either accept it or reject
rejected
and yeah in the end we just put all
these three models together and we get
standardized data hopefully
yeah
yes that's it for the main part i'll
open it up for questions yeah
thank you
uh i have a question that
it's probably understand you just split
the engines like similar changes for
images for attacks and comprised why
don't you use the clip mode or something
like that with a united vector space
so that is again there is a very
good suggestion and i've read some
papers that do that uh at least for the
problems that i've dealt with i didn't
have this images and other information
like that so i didn't try that i didn't
have a chance to try that but yeah there
is some research that actually talks
about that and how sometimes it is
successful yeah that's probably the next
quarter for the matching problem yeah
yeah exactly
so
everybody
can
ask
more questions yeah so uh i just wonder
isn't that the the reasonable to train
the large language model on the whole
sentence so you do the kinetic words by
the space or maybe some uh
i don't know united features of
next words and stuff like that but can
you use the sentence piece for embed the
whole sentences and then you
can solve the similarity problem i guess
that goes back to the
issue of how commonly
how common is your data set like if it's
a very niche data set that is doesn't
appear in a kind of text that those
large models are trained on you the
embeddings wouldn't mean a lot and yeah
problem sometimes you have the amazon
and aliexpress and the languages are
different so
you cannot like obtain the the
dictionaries for this yeah for the fire
phrases for whole languages you have in
the world
yeah that's a good point it'll be also
interesting to see how it plays well
with those niche data sets like if
something is not very common but also
it's in different languages so there are
like two different problems that you
will try to solve simultaneously so yeah
yeah very good point thank you
yeah so does that mean for uh if you
have a website in two languages you do
you will have to do
different data sets and do the process
twice or
uh if we are using this uh you know
sequence of things then probably yes
yeah i couldn't say in other cases so
it'll be interesting to talk about it
later but yeah
and have you tried the human markups
like you did this
synthetic data set as far as i
understood
yes and no so uh for a lot of parts like
in in the data sets at least that i work
with there is some sort of an universal
identifier like for example if you're
dealing with books you have isbn codes
which could be used to label stuff right
so i had at least a small validation
sample so that whenever we build this
synthetic data set we have at least the
holdout set that is uh somewhat well
more reliable than the synthetic data so
yeah that is
how i generally did it
you mentioned treatment so this is the
picture the price and the title but i
think you are you haven't included the
port the most important assortment is
the user which gives clicks so if user
searches something it clicks through
stuff and those images what
the user have clicked those must be
given more weight because those are the
relevant information and i think this
model will be more useful to see the
user the reactions of the user
and record uh i think
that would solve the search relevance
problem so through the clicks you can
understand uh like which was more
relevant for this search query but it
could also be translated into a product
matching problem but not directly it'll
be this indirect
thing like if user searches for
something and then clicks on the first
item and then clicks on the second we
may assume that those two are
be included similar
like a general model as another way like
not only uh
image matching type of natural price
matching but also total machine user
pattern matching
yeah that's an interesting proposition
yeah
if this problem is solvable why is it
that ebay
if you go and you're searching for car
parts for example
unless you filter
multiple items you're going to be
getting a lot of
terrible results
what is
that
i guess is it part of the strategy maybe
it could be could be like yeah
i'm sure
like ebay's product managers could
probably answer that question better
because
yes there is an ability and a lot of
websites are doing this you will see in
amazon or in walmart or any other those
big retailers where there are different
sellers selling the same product you
will see that this problem is already
sold like in amazon if you're looking
for an iphone you're not going to get
hundred difference of iphones you're
just going to get one and then this
offers from different sellers reviews
and everything
yeah
can you elaborate on how can we deal
with the users who are trying to take
and achieve the system
for the name of the product who says
iphone
12 13 or 9
112 and yes
because it's going to match all the
other products right
so do you mean if something's not an
iphone but they label it as an iphone
iphone 12 but in the title
yeah i see
once you i mean my solution to that
would be if you have a model that
understands that iphone 12 is an entity
on its own and then there are like other
products that my model identifies that
there's a
iphone 12 and iphone 13 both in the same
context then that is probably uh not the
right way so i wouldn't let that kind of
name to be inputted so it'll be like a
name restriction it'll throw an error
and say you can put a name like
are this gonna just discard this yeah
and
that's probably depends on the product
in the use case so i can say one would
be better than the other if you are just
on the back end training stuff you can
easily discard and just keep the one
that is that appears most times so if
the name and the description match with
something and that the description
contains a whole lot of other names you
would probably keep the one that matches
and then throw out the rest
that could be one approach
okay
yes
and here at the end i have some links
that
could be relevant so
i'm not sure will this presentation be
shared with the group yeah if yes share
it on the
yeah uh great then yeah these references
you can go take a look
and
thank you